hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast i'm susie valdez of
labrutz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by
leica microsystems for more information
about our sponsor please visit their
site
at leicamicrosystems.com so let's get
started
i want to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble seeing
or hearing this presentation simply
click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to turn it over to our
presenters
dr james maher and dr vikram
coaly for today's presentation welcome
gentlemen you may now begin your
presentations
hello and welcome to today's webinar by
leica microsystems
my name is james marr i'll be joined
with my colleague vikram coley
together we are advanced workflow
specialists for the north america region
as we go through the talk today him and
i will switch back and forth for whoever
is talking we're going to discuss our
thunder imaging platforms
and how they decode 3d biology in real
time
so biology today spans many different
sample types these can be monolayer
cells
to three-dimensional cell cultures
tissue sections
and even model organisms these can be
fixed and live so at the top right we
have an example of
cell migration
and what we're going to focus on today
is our thunder imaging platform and how
it
increases signal and noise gives you
better contrast for your images
and allows easier imaging of thick
samples
these are a few examples highlighted
here you can see on the left
is the wide field image and on the right
is the thundered image
and the goal of today's talk is to
really explain how thunder is applying
to your sample so you get a better idea
of how it improves your imaging
workflow
so at leica we have a broad suite of
products that really support you
from cell culture to your advanced
imaging needs
so we have systems for looking at cell
culture we have sample preparation based
around our
stereoscopes and operate in inverted
microscopes
say our laser micro dissection
microscope we have
products available for routine imaging
histology based on our upright and
inverted microscopes
we of course have our thunder imagers
that we're going to discuss today
we also have confocal platforms based on
our new solaris that launched last year
as well as correlative cryo-em solutions
for doing
electron microscopy and fluorescence
imaging
across many of these products we have a
software suite that is supported on all
of them called
las x this is so that when you switch
between products you're not switching
your user interface you're keeping it
very streamlined in the same
user interface so with these products
we want to really be able to support the
reach and researcher in a very broad
sample type so with our thunder imager
what kind of samples would actually
benefit from them
so researchers have always looked at 2d
cell cultures
recently it's been expanded to 3d cell
cultures like
spheroids neurospheres and even
organoids and micro tissues
researchers also look at tissue sections
either through vibratome or microtome or
other ways
that can result in thin or thick tissue
sections
and they also look at whole model
organisms things like drosophila
mouse embryos zebrafish and c elegans
so with all of these different sample
types wide field has mainly been
restricted to the thinner of those
the reason for this is wide field has a
lot of
inherent out of focus light due to the
way it's
collected what thunder is meant to do
is to bridge the gap and really allow
researchers to image
thicker samples than what regular wide
field would
allow so the way we do this
is by removing the out of focus light or
the background
and we've mentioned this a few times so
what is background what is this blur and
where is it originating from
so this background is actually a
convolution of multiple different
resources
source sources from the sample they can
be
the out-of-focus signal of course which
is a light collected from adjacent
planes in wide-field microscopy
it can be autofluorescence of the sample
and it can also be detector noise
these are just a few examples this
results in an image with blur
and a lack of contrast because our true
signal is riding against
all of this other background signal
which lowers our signal to noise
the goal of thunder is to remove these
out-of-focus sources
and really give a higher contrast better
signal noise on the true signal
so on the right we can see an example of
what thunder would be doing where we
remove that background
and now we have better signal of noise
across our true structural details
so if we go back to that example of a
tumor spheroid we saw a few slides ago
we see on the left we have our
state-of-the-art fluorescence microscope
wide field image it's blurry
it has a lot of background but we can
see our structural details behind that
after thunder the background and blur is
removed
we have better signal to noise and we
can see our structural details much more
easily
in the tumors in the tumor spheroid
so how are we doing this we're doing
this with thunder which is our core
technology
but then we actually have algorithms
beneath that one that is called
instant computational clearing and this
is a proprietary technology from leica
where we remove the out of focus light
through
our computational clearing method
so beyond that being the core technology
of thunder
it is meant to remove the wide field
blur around
a desired object size based on feature
scale or feature size
it's meant to improve image contrast
while preserving the spatial dimensions
of the
image and removing the inherent haze
it works on single images and does not
require a volumetric acquisition
resulting images are also available
instantaneously
given the name instant computational
clearing
so on the right we see a raw image of an
lg test slide
and on the bottom right we see the icc
image
so we can see that the haze is removed
and my structural detail is much more
easily seen
after icc so let's dig a little deeper
into what instant computational clearing
really is so it's a feature scale based
background removal
method it's independent of structural
elements
discrete wavelets and point spread
function modeling
instead it's a mathematical model to
distinguish signal
your true signal from the background or
out of focus light
by implementing a cost function so in
the middle here we have an example of
what the
equation may look like this is a
simplified version
we have a non-quadratic fit where you
have your
original image and the background and
then the regularization term
for minimizing erosion of the signal
in our dialog box in the software it's
implemented with the lightning bolt
and you can set up the parameters that
we'll go through in the next slide
so to go a little deeper into that cost
function the minimization and the
non-quadratic
so y is our input which is our image
what we've collected our wide field
system
x is the background noise that's
estimated to be removed so that's going
to be subtracted from the image
this gamma term is our regularization
term
and it prevents overfitting and erosion
of the data
gamma itself is a regularization
parameter that's proportional to the
full width half max
of the point spread function but in our
dialog box it's commonly referred to
as a feature scale this is a physical
feature
in your image that you would like to
discriminate from out of focus and in
focus and it's what's used to decide
what is out of focus
in the image below that we see strength
strength is the amount of auto focus
light that it tries to remove from the
image
so you can set that between zero and one
hundred percent
a little bit more about this dialog box
you can see that we can set up multiple
channels
and we can actually go between channels
and set different feature scales
and different strengths so you can
really fine tune it
to your sample
going a little bit further we'll give a
few examples of how icc is actually
working
so this next slide is going to give us
an example of how it removes the
autofocus light
so again we're going to be using that
feature scale which is
based on the structures that you've
labeled with fluorescence
you set that here the default value
is proportional to the full width half
max of the point spread function so
default
will give you enhanced contrast just
based on the
point spread function it's user settable
you can fine tune it per image like i
said before but you can also
save these settings and apply them
across multiple images so you're
consistently removing out of focus light
between
images and samples so if we start to
set feature scales we can explain how
it's actually
removing the out of focus light so on
the bottom left here
we see that we have these fine peaks
across
larger peaks and then an overriding
large background
if i set my feature scale to be the
width of this blue
line i'll remove the red line as that's
determined as out of focus light if i
then set my feature scale to be the
finest feature the green line
the green peaks it'll actually start to
remove the blue line as well and give me
a much flatter background across
my true signal
if we take this and we do an example
with an actual sample
say a whole mount retina we can see here
the raw image on the top left
our thundered image on the bottom left
we have a cross section
and we have graph showing what that
cross section looks like
a little more about the sample this is
the red channel looking at retinal
ganglia
and the red dots are the cells
themselves so if we were to want to
quantify this
the raw is has a very non-linear
background where it's going to be hard
to quantify because it's not consistent
after thunder it flattens and we still
have our
true peaks and our true signal but it'll
be much easier to quantify
so it instantly removes the
non-homogeneous background
the post thunder structures and relative
intensities are preserved
and this new thunder data set can be
quantified so
it can easily be segmented or have ratio
metric analysis
performed on it so this is an example of
what it
does to the data if we start looking at
just larger
images overall we have an example here
of chiclen cochlea
where it's a tile scan taken with our 3d
tissue imager
that's based on our upright on the left
we have our wide field
you can see all of the inherent haze and
background
and on the right you can see the image
after thunder
where that haze is removed and we have
better signal noise
higher contrast another example
would be mouse bone on the left is
the raw on the right is the icc'd image
this is a maximum intensity projection
so you can see that we've taken a
z-stack
we've removed the haze and then
collapsed it to a single image to show
you how the structure and the signal
noise has been improved
so to review computational clearing
it's a psf independent process
it's complementary to your workflow and
does have
optional deconvolution which will be
discussed in the next portion
it's meant to be extremely fast meaning
we have that instant
instant computational clearing it's
implemented on the gpu
you get your data instantly with
acquisition
and here we just have a few more
examples showing you how icc improves
image quality
on these adherent cells the background
is removed the signal of noise is
increased
on this mouse lung this is actually a
very hard image to collect because we
used
a 20x air through one millimeter of
plastic
and you can see there's a lot of
autofocus light a lot of blur
due to that and after icc that is
removed and we have
much better contrast and signal to noise
across the features in the organoid
as mentioned by james the core
technology of thunder
is instant computational clearing
icc can be paired with adaptive
deconvolution
to not only improve the contrast of the
image
but also the resolution
the deconvolution offered by leica
microsystems
is an accelerated adaptive richardson
lucy-like
deconvolution that pairs with
computational clearing
its implementation is fully automated
and the deconvolution
is adaptive to changing snr's
signal-to-noise ratios
across the entire image in fact
adaptive snr coefficients are created
and identified
over the entire image and this is shown
here on the right hand side
where regions of high snr are identified
as red
and regions of low snr are identified as
blue
and so the degree of deconvolution as
determined by the amount of
regularization
is dependent on the local snr
in the image the adaptive nature
improves both the image contrast and the
resolution
there are two methods for implementing
this adaptive deconvolution
the first being small volume and the
second
being large volume both of these will be
discussed
a little later
the deconvolution is both regularized
and constrained
using a bayesian statistics approach
with the gaussian noise process
the function to minimize for
deconvolution is presented here
where h star o represents the
convolution
between the gibson lonnie point spread
function psf
with the object the right hand most term
is a term that penalizes
and constrains the deconvolution
and gamma is the regularization term
that scales non-linearly with snr
on the right hand side is the thunder
dialog box as presented
in las x the top portion of the dialog
box
is similar to what has been shown before
and it's the parameters that govern
computational clearing
you can see a variety of channels have
been populated
and each of these channels can have a
different feature scale value
and strength value and to remind you
feature scale is the size of the
structures which your fluorophores are
labeling
and strength is the degree of background
that the user wants to remove
below are the deconvolution settings
and as mentioned decompolation is
implemented
in an automated fashion this means that
the user does not need to select the
number of iterations in order to
converge
the decompolution by using the auto
feature
the algorithm automatically converges
and identifies
the ideal image that is the best
deconvolved image
another parameter is regularization
which as mentioned
scales non-linearly with snr
the default value for the regularization
is 0.05
this is also user-settable and the user
can adjust
this value accordingly i should point
out that regularization is not a
constant value in fact it ranges from
0 to 0.05
and what value is given in the equation
depends on the local snr
we also have an optimization feature
which
is a list of gaussian blurs with
different
kernel radii that's applied to the image
prior to decompolation and this gaussian
bur
blur functions as a way to
frequency filter your data set where
gaussian blur acts as a low pass
frequency filter
as mentioned adaptive snr coefficients
are created over
the entire image this results in the
adaptive
regularization to limit image noise
in artifacts to preserve image detail
we're already familiar with the function
to minimize for deconvolution
and as i mentioned gamma is the
regularization term
that non-linearly scales with signal to
noise
or snr here is the function
that relates to snr where gamma max
is the maximum predefined regularization
so based on the previous slide that
would be a value for the default value
of 0.05
and snr max is the maximum predetermined
snr value so putting this all together
if we consider this heat map which
describes varying levels of
snr throughout the image where red
represents
high snr and blue represents regions of
low snr
adaptive snr coefficients are created
over
the entire image in the amount of
regularization
depends on the local s r
in regions that have high s and r
the regularization value is low
in regions where the s r is poor or low
the regularization value is high
as mentioned there are two
implementations of
adaptive deconvolution the first being
small volume
computational clearing or what is known
as svcc
it combines icc with adaptive
decompolation
an svcc is ideally suited for thin
samples that have
low snr or signal-to-noise ratio
in svcc the adaptive deconvolution is
performed prior
to icc which means that the features of
interest
are enhanced prior to the removal of
background
this is shown here on the right hand
side we can see this raw image
and there is quite a bit of background
in this image
and a lot of the features while they can
be identified are in fact not very clear
but by applying the adaptive
deconvolution
we improve the quality of the structures
of interest
and also we remove the background and so
the result of
svcc is shown here
the other method for implementing
adaptive deconvolution
is large volume computational clearing
or what is known as
lvc it also combines
icc or computational clearing with
adaptive decompolation
and lvcc is meant for samples that have
high snr's and who have background
contributions that are common
in thick samples in lvcc
which is different from svcc
icc is performed prior to
the adaptive deconvolution this means
the background is first removed and then
the remaining signal is treated
through the adaptive decompolution this
is shown here on the right hand side
you notice that the raw image the snr's
are not that bad
and then we have quite a bit of
background that overlays
the image by applying
icc prior to adaptive deconvolution
we remove this background and then treat
the remaining features
by the adaptive deconvolution and the
result here
is shown below
thunder can be performed on the fly
meaning during acquisition
or post acquisition it is important to
mention that the raw data
is always preserved so you always
receive a
secondary data set which is your thunder
data set
we also have a batch processing
algorithm which means that a series of
images can be taken
and process post acquisition using the
batch processing algorithm and such that
the parameters for all of your images
are the same in terms of the thunder
parameters
how does thunder compare to other
imaging modalities
in respects to the size of the point
spread functions
here is a graph or a plot
showing you the size of the psf
for wide field and what the psf would
look like when we apply
icc you'll notice that after icc the
size of the psf
is indeed smaller and this is a
consequence of removing
some of the background but when we pair
icc
with adaptive deconvolution such as in
the case of
lvcc we see a further reduction
in the psf it's not quite as small
as in other modalities such as using
confocal microscopy
and so if increased resolution is
desired leica does
offer confocal products such as the
solaris platform
which can be paired with the
deconvolution called lightning
or you could use the steadx three stead
3x
instead 3x with lightning
thunder is found on a variety of
thunder imagers or microscope platforms
starting from the top left we have the
thunder imager model organism
which is ideally suited for imaging
large
biological systems such as zebrafish c
elegans drosophila or whole mouse
and the reason for this is there's a
large working distance between the
objective
and the sample we also have
a family of upright microscopes like the
thunder image or tissue for slide work
and if you desire to take z-stacks
for some ear slides we have the thunder
tissue 3d
or it's the thunder imager 3d tissue
we also have a family of inverted
microscopes
the 3d cell culture which can be
enclosed with an incubation chamber
to perform 3d live cell and we also have
the thunder imager
3d assay so all of these systems are
equipped with the thunder
technology
throughout this presentation we have
shown you a few images
of what thunder can accomplish and so
we'll continue with that theme
and show you a few more here is an image
of a mouse
long organoid imaged with a 20x
air objective through one millimeter
plastic bottom dish
rendered in 3d this is the image
prior to thunder
and
this is the image after thunder
here is a mouse brain tissue stained
with
gfap and six four seven
this is a 120 micron z stack
and this image is also rendered in 3d
this is the thunder data set
and that's the raw
here's an image of a mouse lung stained
for the at1
lineage this was a 70 micron thick
z stack also rendered in 3d
this is on the left-hand side the raw
data set and on the right hand side
is the thunder data set and this was
processed using
large volume computational clearing or
lvcc
and lastly here's an uncleared human
brain organoid
it was a two by one tile scan there was
four
fluorescent channels and a total z stack
thickness was 285 microns
and this image is a result after
using lvcc
so now we've discussed our thunder
technology
let's see how it's actually applied to
our instrumentation
we've given some examples but we want to
go through some specific hardware
examples that you can use with the
thunder so here we have our 3d cell
culture
it's based on our inverted dmi8 platform
we compare cameras motorized stages and
other things with it
to really give you a high end microscope
so one of the biggest choices any
researcher needs to make
when doing microscopy is to choose the
correct objectives
at leica microsystems we have many
different objectives to choose from
we have water immersion with a micro
dispenser for long-term imaging
motorized correction collars for doing
multi-photon
we even have water or glycerol
objectives to match refractive indices
of your samples we also have ones that
go up to
bab and other types of clearing methods
we also have many with correction
collars for allowing different thickness
of
sample holder to image through so while
we have all of these different options
it may be a little hard to find the one
you need so we've actually come out with
what we call objective finder
and this allows you to search through
our extensive catalog
of objectives and really choose the
objective that's correct for you
and your application so beyond
objective selection the other benefit
you have from going with a
compound microscope like the dmi8
is the ability to use real-time control
of the system
so in many systems when you have a usb
controlled system your illumination will
turn on
it'll tell it to take the exposure and
then it will tell it to turn the
illumination off this time here is
what's needed to communicate that back
and forth in the system
when using a truly synced or
synchronized system like the dmi in our
synapse controller
when we tell the illumination to turn on
and when to expose everything is ttl
triggered
so that our illumination is in line with
our exposure and we are not over
exposing our samples so this is called
synapse
it allows for ttl triggering we can do
this with our
stages our led light sources and even
third-party components so we can control
things not sold by leica as well
this allows for high-speed acquisition
by synchronizing the camera with the
illumination
the synchronization also allows for
minimized light exposure
which minimizes or reduces photo damage
and bleaching of the sample
also on our dmi8 is something that
allows us to create
and keep focus we call this
adaptive focus control it is
a way of locking the objective to the
sample to minimize z
drift due to temperature fluctuations or
mechanical drift
the way this works is that we have a far
red
led light that comes in through the
objective
so being far red it does not expose your
sample to unneeded light
it looks for the back reflection off of
your sample
it works with air and multi-immersion
objectives
so you are not restricted to air or oil
you can bridge all of those
it will lock your focus to the cell
or your sample and then as time
progresses and you have fluctuations in
the system let's say your
sample heats up a bit and it shifts the
focus
up higher without afc your focus would
be now out of focus
but with afc the objective will follow
that thermal fluctuation
and keep the cell in your sample in
focus
so an example of how this works over
time
we have live cell imaging being shown
here
so we're able to keep the cells in focus
by having a rigid stand
but also that hardware called the afc
we can also implement software autofocus
as well
what that really allows you to do is do
long term time lapsing so you can see
down here we have c elegant embryos
and we're imaging those over the course
of multiple hours
we also have cell viability essays
where we're imaging over multiple hours
as well and tracking cell development
and motion
so along with this high-speed imaging in
this afc
we also have stages that allow for
multi-well play imaging
and give you high speed more data points
and overall better statistics because
now you have many more data points
so we can capture capture samples that
go from either slides to well plates so
chamber slides
multi-well plates things like that
through
our custom carriers in our software and
this allows for
automated imaging of those carriers
where you're not setting up by hand
a 96 well play acquisition
with thunder we then have that available
in real time through our computational
clearing and adaptive deconvolution
where as we collect our data at high
speed
we get our end result at high speed as
well
so i've mentioned this custom carrier
this is all
implemented through our software within
las x
it's called navigator this allows you to
identify
areas of interest within las x you can
load
and align and begin imaging with saved
templates
which is being shown here on the right
where they're loading a template
and with that afc and our other focus
control methods we can keep our sample
in focus
over these really large areas so you can
see he's
implemented afc here and now as it goes
along in images in each one of these
chamber slides
the sample is in focus and he's
collecting quality data
so with navigator you can get these very
large mosaic
images of tissue sections you can also
do
multi-weld experiments multi-position
experiments
so here is what we would do with a mouse
slice or a slice of mouth spraying
where we have our thunder image on the
left our raw on the right
so this is a multi-tile acquisition
where we've taken
thunder and then stitched it as a post
process
so to give you a few more examples of
the kind of data you can get off of this
system
we have here a transgenic
prenatal five-day mouse heart that's
expressing
gfp and you can see that we can get a
very large three-dimensional image
with our 10x objective using large
volume computational clearing
and the full thickness of this sample is
740 microns
another example using an organoid this
is actually an organoid cluster stained
with dapi
for the nucleus gfp for the plasma
membrane
and you can see we can get the very
large
overall structure as well as all the
fine structure within that
and this was done with large volume
computational clearing as well
our next example is an adult mouse ovary
that's been fixed and stained with
anti-male box and then cleared with
three
disco you can see that we have
very clear image quality after
deconvolution
this is a very thick sample taken at
almost 600 microns
with our 10x objective
the next example is a whole mouse embryo
stained with beta-3 tubulin and cleared
with bad
this is actually taken with a bab
multi-immersion
refractive index matching objective a
20x multi-immersion objective
so you can see we have a very thick
section
it's 700 microns it consists of 32
stitch tiles
and you can see before thunder we have a
lot of out of focus light
and then after thunder our image quality
is greatly improved with large volume
computational clearing
the next example was mouse brain express
expressing ampk in red and the microglia
with ib one plus in green
it was taken with a 40x 1.3 n a
objective
and both of these images are maximum
projections taken from a 27 micron thick
3d 3d volume you can see with the raw
we have a lot of out of focus light as
well as blur just from
the inherent wide field imaging after
large volume computational clearing
we remove that out of focus light and
enhance our image quality and resolution
this can also be applied to live cell
imaging as well so our next example is
actually a 48 hour
time lapse of live cells being imaged
across
multiple wells this is an explant
tissue of abdominal aorta
it's genetically expressing td tomato
and when a transcription event occurs it
begins expressing
egfp so in our magenta channel is our td
tomato
and you can see the cells that are in
cyan that is now our egfp
and you can see over the course of many
hours going up to
just under 48 hours these cells can be
tracked
and distinguished between td
and egfp
as previously mentioned thunder is
included
in our family of thunder imagers
here's an image of the thunder imager 3d
tissue
it's based on an upright platform
the 3d tissue imager is ideally suited
for imaging
your slide work to see how thunder
can benefit such samples
here are a few examples
here is an image of a neuromuscular
junction
amino stain for neurofilament and beta
bungarotoxin the left hand side of the
image
is the wide field fluorescent image and
the image on the right hand side
is the image after sunder
this is a mouse lung stained for fitzy
psy3 and alexa 633
the image was acquired using a 20x
objective
and the final image was projected into
extended depth of field
or edof the left hand side
is the edof image which is the wide
field image
and the image on the right is the edof
image after thunder
here is an image of a drosophila
rendered in 3d
within our las x software
the stainings were 647 and 555
labeling a subset of motor neurons
here is the image after thunder
and that's the image before thunder
the thunder imager model organism is a
stereo microscope
that is ideally suited for imaging whole
model organisms
such as zebrafish c elegans
drosophila or whole mouse
to see how thunder can be utilized
on such samples here again
are a few examples
this is an image of a cortical spheroid
where red labels neurons and green
labels astrocytes
the image was acquired using a 2x
0.15 na objective
set to a zoom of 3.4
the left hand side is an edof image
taken in wide field fluorescence and the
image on the right hand side
is the edof image after applying thunder
this is an image of a c elegan the
strain was
mah-215
with a dual fluorescent reporter of m
cherry
and gfp the image on the left-hand side
is the wide-field fluorescent image and
the image
on the right hand side is a result
after thunder
here we have an image of a c anemone
stained in rfp and ngfp
notice how you can clearly see gfp
signal around the mouth and in bands
in some of the tentacles this result
after thunder
here is a mouse heart
stained for th positive neurons
it's rendered in 3d within our las x
software
the total z stack thickness was
400 microns here is the result
before thunder and that is the result
after thunder
and lastly this is an image of a mouse
brain
the left hand side is before thunder
and the right-hand side is after
applying thunder
so hopefully with these images we have
shown you you now can appreciate the
power of using thunder
the ability to see through the haze to
increase image contrast and also
image resolution
with that we'll finish on the last and
newest member to the thunder imaging
family
the em cryo clem so the em cryo clem
is an upright based microscope to allow
you to image your samples at cryogenic
temperatures
and then do a coordinate transfer to
your cryoem
or em microscope to then do high
resolution imaging
on those same areas
so the main benefit of the cryo-em
is being able to determine sample
quality and location
before going to the cryo-em to do
high-resolution imaging
so you can image across the grid and
look at your sample quality
identify areas that are not good for
imaging like
crystalline ice contamination and then
identify areas that are good
and would be suitable for em imaging
so you can see here we have intact
meshes with
our cells growing across them
good fluorescent signal we could mark
these and then take them to our cryoen
so as mentioned you can identify and
mark potential targets
so here we have a fluorescence cell of
interest
we could mark it as a coordinate we
could do this across
the entire image or the entire grid
and then once we go to our scanning
electron microscope or our cryoem
we could do a coordinate transfer find
those exact same cells
and image them at high resolution and
even do tomography
another large benefit is being able to
maintain cryo conditions through all of
this process
this maximizes your ability to
successfully find
samples of interest and get good
experimental outcomes
while minimizing the potential of
contamination during loading
and transferring of your sample this is
done by keeping your sample at cryogenic
temperatures
we do this with a cryogenic stage an
objective that works at cryo conditions
and then a shuttle that shuttle your
tran your sample
at cryogenic temperatures between our
system
and your cryo-em with this
and with the fluorescence imaging we've
now added thunder
to the to this as well and on this next
slide you can see as we peel away
we have our raw versus our thundered
image
so with the thunder we get higher
resolution
better image contrast and overall a
better
easier way of marking coordinates for
transferring to the cryoe
these are human cells staying with gfp
and m cherry
and we can target them now with
coordinates that we could transfer
to our cryo-em and then do
high-resolution imaging across them
so that being said we'd like to finish
on two important parts
of our thunder imaging family one being
the publications that have come out so
far for our
instrumentation thunder was launched
in 2019 and since then we've had over 60
publications
using thunder imaging we've taken a
couple selection from that
we have one based on cancer looking at
drug resistance and melanoma
and thunder imaging of cells we have one
in neurobiology
looking at membrane trafficking in brain
slices
using a thunder imager and then last we
have one in
biotechnology looking at conductive
protein dye microfibers
and using a thunder imager to look at
the fluorescence there
so we have this publication list
available on our website
listed here on this link if you'd like
to find it
by searching you can search for leica
microsystems
thunders publication list
and the second piece we'd like to finish
on is quantification
always a major part in any fluorescence
imaging is quantification
this is not an exhaustive look at
quantification but we'd like to give a
few examples of how people can use our
systems
for quantification this first one being
counting so this is a brain slice where
we're looking at neurons
in a mouse brain and we want to count
them but we also want to look at the
co-localization
of our green and red channels so this
image on the bottom left
is our brain slice our our thundered
image
the image on the top right is of
counting those neurons so each one of
these points
is a neuron that has been counted and
then the image below
is looking at the co-localization
between the green red channel where we
can now
count when cells of two different colors
are touching each other
is important for this because when we
apply deconvolution we're getting
better image quality but also better
image resolution which gives you better
localization you'll get better
counting and localization with it
the second one we'd like to show is
ratio metric analysis
this is of an arabidopsis expressing
gfp as we apply
a catalyst peroxide
we can use our sensors to look at the
response of the arabidopsis
and in time we can see how it responds
to that
injection of a of peroxide in the
calcium expression channel
so this is a way of doing ratio metric
analysis with the thunder imagers as
well
again not exhaustive but it is a very
important question that we'd like to
answer
and show so with that we'll
finish with a review of the thunder
imager family
again we have three main instruments
that it's based upon
our male organism which is on our
stereoscope
our 3d tissue on our upright dm6
and our 3d cell culture on our dmi8
the main part or the reason that we
brought thunder
to the customer is to allow for
getting brilliant images fast we also
wanted to allow for effortless work
with new models like organisms
tissue sections and 3d cell cultures
and really allow people to take
advantage of next generation disease
models
not having a restriction to the hardware
they have
so thunder imagers are a new class of
imaging system that rely on
cameras for detection and high quality
hardware
and leica's computational clearing
technology to remove out-of-focus light
and with all of that we hope that you're
able to see through the haze
and see how thunder can benefit you and
your samples
to finish i would like to give you an
idea of who's been talking to you for
the last hour or so
we have vikram coley he's the midwest
advanced workflow specialist
and then you have myself james marr the
mid-atlantic
advanced workflow specialist you can see
that we have our emails listed if you
have any additional questions after this
feel free to reach out we also have a
remote application support line that you
can contact
as well as a youtube channel with
tutorials on how to use our hardware
and our software and with that we'll
take any questions
and thank you so much for joining us for
this webinar have a good day
and thank you so much dr maher and dr
coley for that informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
i would also like to welcome levy velts
who will be joining us
for the q a portion if you have any
questions you'd like to ask
please do so now
ask a question box and we will
directly go ahead and answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
levy welcome and it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in our first question
you mentioned the deconvolution
is regulized regulate regularized and
constrained
what is the regularization used
hi uh yeah thank you for these questions
um we've got a few of them here in the
chat and i've tried to respond to some
uh directly uh via via the response so
hopefully you're getting those
um yeah when we think about the
regularization
and constrainment of deconvolution and
what does it mean
either there's there are different
methods that exist
to regularize the deconvolution to to
limit
image noise um to limit artifact
generation
ultimately that the goal here is to
preserve overall image details
so there are techniques like um tiknahov
miller
total variation as a couple of examples
that are used
but for thunder primarily we're using
goods roughness as as the regularization
algorithm that's being used to help
preserve these image details
thank you so much and what does svcc
and lvcc vary in the order of
deconvolution
and icc
yeah so if we remember back svcc is our
small volume computational clearing
lvcc is large volume computational
clearing and icc
is interactive computational clearing
and each one of these can be done
independently
but and it depends on a lot of different
factors
sample thickness is a primary factor
the signal-to-noise ratio is a primary
factor the amount of background presence
so if you're measuring a fixed sample
with a lot of background
deconvolution on its own can fail to
produce a restored image
so what we would use would be the large
volume so large volume is going to do
computational clearing first and then
apply deconvolution
but if you have a give a sample that
maybe there's poor signal noise or it's
very thin
you would want to do deconvolution first
in the workflow and then do
computational clearing and that's where
you'd use small volume
computational clearing so there's a lot
of different
factors that go into which one that
you're choosing
thickness signal to noise ratio
background
most of the the samples we're looking at
we've seen people use the
large volume computational clearing is
is the default mode that they'll go to
but if you're looking at something
that's very thin or has a very weak
signal of noise
you can switch modes and and all of the
modes are you can try them both
because it's done computationally um you
can try one you can try the other and
see which is giving you
the result you're looking for and then
there are
other optimization parameters you can
use in the software to
to really customize the
the experiment to fit your the
sorry the analysis to fit your
experiment thank you so much levi
and our next question from an audience
member can thunder be applied
to bf images
no yeah bf so we're what we're talking
about is brightfield
um and in short the answer is no so
thunder is really uh applied to the
fluorescent channels
so within our software system las x
for people using like a micro system
microscopes
um if there is a multi-channel
acquisition set up with a bright field
channel
um the brightfield channel is skipped as
part of the algorithm
so they're all we're only applying
fluorescence i'm sorry we're only
applying
thunder imaging computational clearing
to the fluorescence channels
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
we have time for one more question is
the data
quantifiable so
so james mentioned this um on the last
couple of slides
and and quantifiability again is a
variable
in the community that we we work in
so we can think about is it quantifiable
from a segmentation analysis
analysis perspective is it is it
quantifiable from
a fluorescence intensity measurement
ratio metric analysis all of these
things
but post thunder the data sets can be
quantified for segmentation and cell
identification and cell counting
um fluorescence intensity and and we can
preserve
all of these relative uh fluorescence
intensities so
yes it is quantifiable um and
the the one of the key aspects we have
with our
our thunder imager platform
is you always have the raw
data to to look at and compare to
so when you're measuring peak heights or
what's changed we don't overwrite the
the raw data we don't delete the raw
data the raw data is always there
and then the computational clearing and
the thundering of your samples are all
done
um you know
as a separate module to work with so you
can always
compare and contrast but um but yeah
those are those are all
there's still some other questions in
the chat um we can
we'll take these questions down and
we'll email you directly the answers
because i know we're running uh towards
the end of time here but
these are all great questions and thank
you so much levi for your participation
with the q
a and i also want to thank dr mar and dr
coley for their time and for their
important research and i remind audience
that questions we do not have time for
today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information
you provided at the registration i'd
also like to thank lab routes
and our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's
educational webcast you can view the
webinar on demand and labyrinths will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay that's
all for now until next time
take care everyone bye